hey hey hey hey click click click click
boom lef koe man with the sharpest man
in football Warren Sharpe I have to go
to New Orleans
my brother is getting married Warren and
he wants to have a party beforehand and
then I'm going to London O'Neill's on
Carnaby Street and I'm gonna teach
people in Britain I don't even know if
they call it that
UK I'm an idiot how to watch football on
Sundays Warren so we're doing this is
coming out Thursday a little early
edition how you feeling I'm feeling good
I like the little Thursday early edition
for the people get this information out
to him soon or looking forward Warren
you were you were in the in the DC area
correct yep okay so also in the DC area
is Josh Norman if you haven't checked it
out yet go watch ditch the playbook with
Josh Norman we took a tour of his wild
house
he has Conan the Barbarian sward he has
a bed that rumbles and shakes he has a
ridiculous old muscle car and he's just
kind of a weird dude so check out ditch
the playbook retweet it and say man this
episode was phenomenal and I will
retweet you that's how I work it's an
easy give-and-take
so Ron where you don't really record on
Thursdays what part of your flow are you
in since we're recording this on a
Wednesday in your weekly flow so I've
run all my models last night late about
3:00 a.m. I was updating my strength of
schedule for sharp football stats
so all that's up there now when we're
going to be talking about some of that
Here I am working on a couple of
strategical game plan type things for
for some teams and I'm also
just continuing to break down these
games I dig like more and more detail
because as we're recording this new
injury reports start to come out sure
you need to get that information as
we're processing it here as we're in the
middle part of the season warning I want
you to make me a deal if something pops
up injury related either I'm talking
about it or it sees it and I miss it
just say it because we're recording this
at around 11 o'clock on Wednesday and
this is when the first injury reports
come out but as we saw last week you
can't rely too much on that like Dallas
was a perfect example that Wednesday
injury report came out you were like I'm
all over the Eagles and then comes
Sunday
the injury report was practically the
entire team was healthy and so sometimes
that stuff is misleading
it absolutely is now I will say just now
DeSean Jackson remains sideline he did
not practice for the Eagles today which
is not that unexpected but it's week
eight now and we that by you know it's
not unexpected from what we were talking
about last week or the week before but
when they start and talking about this
injury back in week two we thought he'd
be back by at this point in time in
terms of that game you're absolutely
right we certainly went when that line
was fiddly plus three and they were
talking about
Lael Collins Tire and Smith Amari Cooper
plus maybe some Cobb yeah
all injured plus two starting
quarterbacks have not been practicing
for the Cowboys it was like there is no
way this line should be Philly plus
three with this injury health situation
but as it turns out by the time we
actually got to Sunday night whole team
was healthy more healthier than the
Eagles because the Eagles were without
their starting left tackle they were
still missing guys in the secondary yep
still without the Sean Jackson so it
ended up flipping on us pretty quick so
I have been getting a lot of dm's wired
I did not tell you this last night of
people saying that they love sharp
school and people are sending me
pictures in the DMS of notebooks of all
the notes they take while they're
listening to the show and I'm seeing a
lot of people circling EDS are I'm
seeing a lot of people circling some
strength of schedule stuff a lot of that
coming up later in the show
but that's the best way I think to watch
this show is if you want to be a passive
listener
that's the way podcasts are I totally
get it on the train whatever but if
you're trying to bet like I spend my
Saturday is listening to a bunch of
people writing down notes if you're
listening to this show take some notes
because a lot of this information is
gonna fly by
but in sharps couloir and sometimes we
have students that are excelling Kyle
Shanahan for example gold star and
sometimes you have some students that
need to be brought to class on a
Saturday and given detention and that's
kind of how I feel about Pete Carroll
right now part of its because i watched
some questionable decision-making and
then I started seeing our good friend
Mina complaining about and I'm starting
to see the analytics community going
right now what does Pete Carroll doing
are you seeing some some questionable
decision-making that that you think he
might need sharp school detention yeah
unfortunately look I like this Seahawks
in general but we know heading into that
we knew heading into the season they
have somewhat of an antiquated mentality
when it comes to what wins in football I
sure love to run the football
they love to control time of possession
they think that this helps their defense
they think that this will wear down the
opponent and we've debunked a lot of
those myths already but they also
struggle with some of the key things
that for example I mean it didn't factor
into the game last week but like Doug
Peterson and Bill Belichick and some of
the newer school coaches are excelling
with Frank Reich who we're going to talk
about all of it which is down
decision-making when to kick when not to
kick and they really struggle with that
and they certainly struggle with a big
time in their game against the Baltimore
Ravens and it was a big difference
because John Harbaugh was very
aggressive and we know Pete Carroll was
very conservative yeah the big thing was
there was a 53-yard field goal that the
seattle seahawks kicked and pete carroll
said after the game on that fourth down
quote we're kicking it that's what we do
that's what our mentality is going to be
and there's no reason to change and you
looked it up and not only are the
seattle seahawks phenomenal in the
the field on 4th down there insanely
phenomenal like what are the statistics
about Russell Wilson and and the Seattle
Seahawks ability to get fourth down
conversions Seattle has converted 28 of
31 fourth and short opportunities in the
second half of games when in opponent's
territory since Russell Wilson came to
town in 2012 that's when I'm 31 is
insane it's almost impossible to do any
better than that I couldn't even fathom
that's 90% fourth down conversion rate
90 percent and the postseason and if you
also factor in just at home he's 16 of
17
that's 94 percent it's ridiculous and
it's ridiculous also to have the
mentality that there's no reason to
change this is our your exact quote this
is our mentality and there's no reason
to change well hello mr. Carroll have
you looked at the statistics because
there should give you a reason to change
those should present a desire to and
this isn't like league-wide numbers
right like John Harbaugh with the Ravens
looks at league wide trends but you also
have to factor in what your own team is
good at what are your team's trends and
in a game where you're tied 13 to 13
you're on the opponent's 35 yard line so
it's going to be a 53-yard field goal
attempt your kicker has already proven
to be a little shaky this year yes yes
light rain up in Seattle do you realize
that your quarterback is converting 28
of 31 of these attempts including 16 of
17 at home and you can actually convert
and then go down and score touchdown
instead of risking missing a field goal
and setting up a shorter field for the
Baltimore Ravens I don't think he has
access to these numbers if so not using
them in his decision-making which is the
exact opposite of horrible what we're
doing right now is we're doing two
things one has two people that bet the
over and that missed it by about a field
goal we're getting this out of our
system right now because I think when
you watch that game the missed field
goals that the conservative
decision-making boy I wanted to punch
people in the face but
the second thing we're doing is Seattle
wants to make a run and I watch the best
teams the NFL the Patriots the
offensively the Chiefs that when they
get into an aggressive mindset those are
the teams that win games right now and
so it's just a little concerning when
you see a team of Seattle with an MVP
caliber quarterback making these
decisions it could bite you later on and
we're trying to get this out there now
so the Seattle Seahawks can adapt the
Ravens have adapted Lamar Jackson has
been wonderful and I was curious because
I didn't see Russell Wilson have a lot
of success
I saw them get Marcus Peters and I asked
you look we've been all over the Ravens
all year about their inability to defend
three wide receivers was it better last
game or was that kind of a wash in that
it was too defensive turnovers for
Baltimore they gave them the edge no it
absolutely was better Baltimore against
three wide sets we talked about what
happens when the defense when the
offense spreads you out into three wide
sets they only allowed a 69 percent six
yards 69 sorry
the only six point nine yards per
attempt and a 44 percent success rate to
11 personnel which is a big improvement
over what they done year-to-date where
was eight point seven yards per attempt
and a 48 percent success rate this game
actually came down to a lot of Russell
Wilson I was actually a little bit
surprised I went back looked at the game
because as you mentioned one of the
things that I was on was the over in
this game and what I decided to do and I
mentioned on the show last week there
was a game I might be looking at split
in first half and full game we talked
about that a little bit when I was boy
as to like what game that was going to
be it ended up being this game
I bet the over 24 in the first half
which one the over 48 in the second half
which lost but I'm not waited I waited I
waited that's part of the big thing of
being a pro better is market timing and
I saw that with weather concerns the
line might drop I saw with the Baltimore
Ravens number one wide receiver actually
being ruled out margins I was hoping he
was going to play that was another
reason why
total drop but in terms of what a good
thing that Seattle actually did here is
they put the game a little bit more on
the shoulders of Russell Wilson I was
worried when I went back and looked at
the numbers that we were gonna have this
ultra uber conservative approach from
Brian Schottenheimer with a lot of runs
and very few passes and that's why
Seattle's offense wasn't really clicking
but if you look inside of the 40-yard
line as the Seahawks are driving to
score a touchdown and the only a forty
yards or less to go they only ran the
ball six times they passed it 21 times
well six rushes rated out as successful
they were doing well when they ran the
football but Russell Wilson struggled
mightily against this Ravens past the
offense only seven of his 21 pass
attempts graded out as successful that's
like 32% 33% so he really 3% Warren say
it right
30% so they did not have a good day
passing the football and actually a guy
from Seattle told me ahead of time and
Russell Wilson has not been the best
when it's raining so that's something to
fathom any weather as we move forward
throughout the course of the year we
need to be paying close attention to the
weather but look back and see some of
the results of Russell Wilson in the
rain he definitely did not have his best
game this time and I know we were both
are very excited out the Ravens going
forward when they get Jimmy Smith back
when they add him with Marcus Peters and
Humphrey the fact that Lamar Jackson is
really doing this without any big
weapons right now not not even just
excited for the Ravens this season but
like the next two years could could
really be really special for Baltimore I
think we both see it it's it's crazy if
you talk the receiving core of the
Baltimore Ravens and put another
quarterback back there every single one
of them would struggle mightily you
don't have Marquis Brown he hasn't been
there for weeks what are the receivers
do these guys even have right who it is
they're number one they're using the
tight end
you drop a bunch of balls in that game
for starters but they have a tight end
as their number one receiver right now
he's not Travis Kelce level tight end or
you know Rob Gronkowski level tight end
and then their other
receivers are just like I would argue
that those guys are as replaceable as
most running backs in the league to be
honest those guys are at Willie Snead
and Boykin that he's got cannot work
anything special to write home about so
what Lamar Jackson has had to do is put
more on his shoulders from the ground
game and try to do the best that he can
through the air until he gets his number
one marques back
all right so Seattle listen go for it on
fourth and short and the other opponents
territory
keep throwing it with Russell Wilson a
pretty good ratio but as you get down
there run the ball you have been taken
to sharps school now let's get to Warren
sharps baby EDS are extra damn smooth
results that's what it stands for early
down success rate and that as well I
went back and looked thus far Warren has
given us the eight biggest mismatches of
the last two weeks week six and week
seven thus far seven and one overall and
then against the spread not as reliable
three and five against the spread but
this is more the matchups and to be
honest we're starting to see the biggest
lying differences popping up but in
terms of the two upsets it gave us it's
now to an O Pittsburgh over the Chargers
in week six Saints over the the Bears in
week seven and both of them were like
monster wins for upsets we see some big
spreads what are your biggest mismatches
in early down success rate for week
eight weren't sharp yeah and and and
first before we get into that I just
want to mention the fact that early on
success rate is an awesome tool to be
able to kind of look at which teams
might have edges which teams may not
which teams might struggle but when
you're talking about like some of these
games we're gonna get into not so much
this week but in weeks past where it's
like a 17 point favorite a 14 point
favorite I'm never really in favor of
laying those types of lines so the fact
that that team wins but doesn't cover is
really not the biggest shock and so far
we've mentioned a number of games where
it's like New England or like huge
favorites but this week we've got two
teams that do have big lines and they're
favored with big mismatches the FIR
one is the Rams the Rams playing over in
London they're favored by 13 points
they've got a pretty big mismatch from
early down successors the largest of the
week number two is the Buffalo Bills at
roosting your philadelphia eagles the
philadelphia coast as we've mentioned
previously on the show last week they
struggle on early downs they've
struggled both offensively and
defensively they ranked in the bottom
third of the league
Buffalo has been surprisingly strong
from early downs which I liked Buffalo
going into this season but I certainly
was surprised by their early down
success rate so that's me fascinating
matchup because they're only favored by
point in half next we've got the New
Orleans Saints almost favored by double
digits just under that and rounding out
the the fourth biggest EDS are mismatch
between you know a team offense defense
versus an opponent is again the New
England Patriot this week over the
Cleveland Browns they're laying thirteen
points right now as we're recording them
so the Rams Saints and Patriots are all
favored by nine or more points so those
really aren't that surprising but I feel
like when you saw the bills pop up I
would imagine there was party that was
like oh I know that what my models
saying but this is a little bit scary to
me yeah and the funny part is like when
we're talking about these things we're
investigating him live in real time on
the phone you and me are having a phone
call late at night before we do this
show and when I said the the bills you
know it definitely was like ooh
interesting you know they're laying less
than a field goal at home against a team
that has been to the playoffs each of
the last two years as one playoff games
and and you're saying that they have a
better
edie SR mismatch against the Eagles than
the Patriots do against the Browns and
the Saints have you know that that to me
it's just it's interesting but at the
same point I have pause so when you see
that how do you process that dynamic I
look at it as the fact that if the
Eagles want to stand a chance to win
this game they've got to force Josh
Allen into third downs defensively
they've got to figure out a way to do
that and then offensively this is a very
good Buffalo Bills defense
and they need to come out and figure out
a way to balance their ability to avoid
third downs with getting explosive plays
and the reason I say balance that is
because if you focus too much on like
getting these big chunks down the field
inevitably those are so high variants
that you'll find yourself in second and
really long which is hard to bypass
third down then your gut probably going
to be in a third down in that situation
or you shoot your shot play on a second
down it doesn't get complete doesn't
gain the first time then you find
yourself in a third down so you have to
balance trying to be aggressive with not
and the bills defense you it's hard to
matriculate the ball down the field
converting third downs against this
defense right they just picture a team's
Drive they start on their 25-yard line
they have to get to the opposing end
zone how many plays do you think you're
gonna be able to go down the field
without making mistake without taking
the sack without having something to set
you behind the sticks that could force
you then to punt the football so it's
just difficult you want to try to get
chunk plays against them but at the same
time you want to be realistic and set up
for success not gonna lie when I saw the
Eagles were a point half-dog against the
Buffalo Bills team that barely went out
there and beat the Dolphins I was
looking at Philly but now as you're
saying this and I'm thinking about the
fact that the Eagles are not gonna have
to show in Jackson again and they're
gonna have to go with Al Shean and
Earths and Goddard and find a way to
move the ball slowly you're playing into
the bills strategy because the bills
they do have a guy that can take the top
of a defense and smoke John Brown should
have a lot of success against this
Philly secondary so a matchup that I
thought Oh interesting I'm getting the
Eagles that maybe they could bounce back
after an embarrassing Sunday Night
Football game and be angry yeah but this
is a Bills team that you're gonna have
to play their type of football so that
that you know could be interesting so I
said Warren look three of your EDS are
miss miss matches are huge favorites do
you have any in which the underdog
actually has the EDS our mismatch I'm
going to give you guys a warning Warren
always feels more comfortable about the
top four
after that it's a little bit more even
but you do have some matchups where the
underdog has the eds our advantage
correct yes we do and again like we
shouldn't necessarily count these
towards the to know is the best
underdogs right right but the Giants
plus seven over the Lions is very
fascinating to me because if you compare
EDS are to like DVO a which is a
football outsider's metric which looks
at efficiency I am much higher my EDS
are is higher on the Giants than they
are they rank the Giants as one of the
worst six teams in the league in terms
of overall efficiency my EDS are has
them definitely higher than that and you
know so that's one thing where they also
are much higher on the Detroit Lions and
EDS are is a little bit lower it's
interesting Detroit is now going to be
without carry on Johnson and they just
traded away their starting strong safety
to Seattle Seahawks so he was really
good in run defense and carry on was the
guy who was running the football for
them and what do we know about the Lions
with Matt Patricia they want to run the
ball and stop the run that's kind of
their identity like Matt Patricia
conservative old-school guy they like
running the football and so are they
gonna have success without carry on I
think they still could
I don't know that carry on is like
beyond replacement right but do they
have a guy on that roster who's really
gonna do the same job adequately and are
they going to continue to run the ball
or are they gonna seep a little bit more
into the pass game and we know that
locker room I mean you can share with
the 33% they were not happy when that
trade it went down yesterday no I mean
carry on Johnson went on IR but he still
felt the need to tweet out rough day ir
and we lost quandary digs and you're
like wow like the fact that you're
you're so upset that it's equal to you
going on injured reserve is is very
telling every player came out including
I was called Andre Bligh Darius slay
came out as well when you see that
you're metric is so different than a
metric like DVO a that is so wildly
popular does that give you concern or
does that in your mind go this is
something I'm gonna be
take advantage of with public perception
a little bit of both I still don't know
how public D VOA is right a lot of the
smarter analytical folks do use it but
you know the mainstream guys who are
betting on these games or like the
syndicate groups you know I don't know
how much those guys are factoring they
certainly are factoring in a little bit
more than others the guys that do a lot
more reading into their games you know
by reading I mean like they're reading
teams and getting information inside
information and stuff like that those
types of guys don't really probably
factor it in all that much but I do look
at it as an edge I mean look at the
49ers for an example they were a team
that D VOA had ranked very low last
season and I was top ten offensively and
defensively and they obviously solved
their turnover problem got their
starting quarterback back and are
undefeated right now this year so there
are definitely opportunities when that
occurs and there is significant
difference but the other thing you have
to do is you have to take an
acceleration like I take a step back and
look at okay why might the Giants be you
know rank a little bit higher than DB
away so I do look what did you what did
you come up with with that well with the
Giants one of the things that they had
been doing especially once they got once
they made the quarterback change is I
felt like their scripting in their game
planning was a lot better and they were
avoiding some of those third down
situations they have tailed off a little
bit over the last few weeks in terms of
EDS are but the other thing was I'm
probably also waiting their schedule a
little bit stronger into it if you look
at the Giants schedule yeah and rudl
it's one of the reasons why we thought
Eli probably wouldn't be long there and
we were betting like over in the number
of starts for the rookie quarterback
because that schedule has been brutal
and so when you look at their overall
EDS our metrics they're like right
around 20th but when you factor in the
strength of schedule that definitely
yeah them into the upper realm Cowboys
Bills Vikings Patriots for the teams
they've already faced the other the
other team or the other matchup that
that in which the
Sr was better for the underdog than the
favorite is in my mind the regression
Bowl which is the Bears and the Chargers
where both teams if you were their fan
bases before this season all the media
was talking about I could see them
taking a step back and those fan bases
were frantically yelling to anyone that
would listen know the Bears are going to
be fine
know the Chargers won seven of eight on
the road last year they will be fine
both of them well at least the Chargers
were phenomenal in one score games last
year they've regress tour two and five
which is wild and they're so talented
and the Bears were looking at right now
that seemed incomplete free fall the fan
base has lost all faith in Mitchell true
Biscay their head coach Nagy has gone
from coach of the year to people going
is he a complete fraud they're playing
egg toss at practice and now these two
teams whoever loses I mean that fan base
is in you're not making the playoffs
ville like your season is over
and so in yours the the chart that
Chicago Bears at home as recording our
four point favorites and you actually
see the Chargers with an EDS our
advantage here which is not surprising
right and and I ranked kind of like the
Philadelphia Eagles EDS are is very low
on the Chicago Bears lower than D vo a
right now and so you know that was that
was something about the Philadelphia
Eagles you know we the dbo a it has him
about 15 EDS are hasn't much worse than
that
but with the Chicago Bears absolutely I
don't really understand some of the play
calling that they've been doing I mean
and this is a perfect example I'll just
talk about this example from the game
last week against the Saints that games
what 12 to 10 in the third quarter
right so it's a close competitive game
the the Saints haven't exploded to their
lead yet but over the course of the game
so for the vast majority this games a
one score game right that game I don't
understand what Nagy is doing fifty-six
Mitchell true Biscay
facts only seven rushing attempts how is
that possible Mitchell is 12 term yeah
whiskey's coming back from a multi gain
absence due to a shoulder injury he's
wearing a harness he's not a good
quarterback you have to micromanage him
and you're throwing the ball 56 drop
backs and only seven rushing attempts
and I understand your rushing attempts
weren't all that successful but figure
out a way to get more successful runs
against the Saints and I can guarantee
in no world is the recipe to beating the
Saints have Travis key drop back 56
times so that's going to result in bad
early down success that's going to
result in a lot of plays where you're
forced into third down because of first
and second down failures I also I don't
know if I can ever bet on this game like
that the betting on the Chargers is it's
like playing Russian roulette at this
point also how about that great Bears
defense that everyone was like oh yeah
man they're gonna be fine they're gonna
lose Fangio okay they've allowed 60
points the last two weeks last two times
they've played to the Raiders and the
Saints too to the Raiders and Teddy
Bridgewater but like I know that you're
giving me an EDS our advantage but like
we're frustrated the Bears I'm equally
as frustrated with the Chargers hey I
don't know if I could do that as you
should be and one of the key things with
the Chargers that just is mind boggling
is you have a running back who's not
worth what he wants to get so he decides
to hold out and he doesn't do anything
in training camp with your team he
doesn't do anything for the first what
four games of the season then all sudden
he comes back maybe he came back the
fourth the fourth game but didn't play
the last three weeks you start giving
him the majority of the carries and he's
not good he's causing major problems for
the charters offense those rushing
attempts have been very unsuccessful if
you look up on the chart football stats
you can see there's a page which will
show you
trending performance like on a week to
week basis so you can go you know week
for week five weeks six weeks seven and
look as
trendline decreases there as they're
giving him more carries the success rate
of the ground game continues to decrease
and decrease and decrease and that
trendline is going way down to the
ground and forcing the more care just
like giving mitchell Biscay more drop
backs to pass the ball is not the answer
giving melvin gordon more rushing
attempts is not the answer for the
chargers so and i don't know why they
didn't sneak the freaking ball i even
wrote about philip rivers and his
inability to sneak the football for
years it's been a problem I actually
wrote an entire article dedicated to it
I analyzed the quarterback sneak in the
house how rare do they actually run the
sneak with the Chargers Philip Rivers I
think has four four rushing attempts in
short maybe it's six rushing attempts in
short yardage situations over the last
like six or seven years and most of them
have been situations where he's botching
the snap and then just picking it up and
getting tackled it's not an actual
designed sneak because I went back and I
watched the film on every single one of
the plays because I was like well is he
just terrible at sneaky and that's why
they're not doing no you know Philip
what Philip Rivers does is he waits
until the final seconds of the play
clock so how's this running down and
there's four seconds if he's telling
guys don't move this why do this do this
get over here okay
then he starts staying in violence under
like kind of clap the ball real quick
when there's one second left he gets the
ball and he like bobbles it through his
hands and then the defense collapses on
him there is never a time when he gets
to the line quickly like Tom Brady and
just sneaks the ball and goes forward
like that just does not exist and you
know dr. Chow was like I asked him
please when you bring Phillip Rivers on
your podcast asked him about why he
doesn't sneak and rivers games like the
politically correct response like well
I'm not against quarterback sneaks but
at the same time that's why we have a
running back who's big and strong and a
lot better than me at getting these
first downs and I'm thinking this is the
result of not having an analytics
department they have not had an
analytics department for the charters
for years they're starting to work on
that but this is why you are missing
your starting quarterback who is your
entire team because everybody else drops
like flies he's played all 16 games for
years and years and years and all the
other guys around him his tight ends his
wide receivers keep getting injured his
offensive lineman and you aren't
informing this guy that every time he's
turning around to hand the ball to a
running back he's 25% less likely to get
a first down then if he just got the
ball and snuck it forward like you're
misinforming him he doesn't understand
what's efficient and now your team is
suffering and you have that opportunity
to win a game and of course they lost
that felt was that since Melvin Gordon's
comeback like we literally have faded
the Chargers twice took Denver on this
show outright and stem that was the
first time that Melvin Gordon came back
and in my analysis of what I share with
my clients I said I hope that they start
trying to feed melvin bored on the ball
because this is gonna be a good reason
to bet against this team and then i
didn't do anything
the week but week 7 in tenant with vs.
Tennessee I actually took Tennessee now
I didn't feel good about that wager as
the games playing outright that game was
a total coin flip fortunate to actually
win that one in the way that it went
down but it's it's just an example that
feeding Melvin Gordon a ball like that
is not a good strategy no it's it's Wow
the one thing too about this what was I
gonna say don't not Chargers Bears the
the thing that I always think about when
you were talking right there about
Phillip Rivers he's the one apparently
deciding if they're gonna sneak or not
is when I was doing the show with Sims
and it was the Patrick mahomes to Shaun
Watson try Biscay draft the big rumor
that he was hearing we talked about on
the show is that the Chargers wanted to
draft a Shaun Watson at 7 that's what
they wanted to do but they went to
Philip and Philip said I think we can
still win we should draft Mike Williams
instead and they did and so when you
factor in the fact that you know not
only is he controlling cute quarterback
sneaks
he's probably controlling all of the
plays it's probably why does hurry up so
he doesn't have to listen to the play
callers they don't have analytics to
check on he's deciding if they're gonna
draft the next franchise quarterback or
not and you look at that whole franchise
and you go WOW here I was thinking that
Eli was kind of holding the Giants
hostage but in a weird way like because
we like Philip Rivers we like his
personality and he's kind of funny when
he's not on your team
he in a weird way what he's doing with
that franchise is kind of similar well I
do I'm interested in the law the
reasoning of why he said not to draft
him obviously if you asked any starting
quarterback in the head why would they
want to draft their eventual replacement
they want to draft a guy like deshaun
Watson to replace him number one but
number two like maybe they asked him you
know Philip like we need we're worried
about how this is going how many more
years are you planning on playing you're
starting to get older like how many more
years are you playing because if it
might only be a couple and you really
want to get out of here go ahead raft
Watson and maybe Philips like no man I
got like five seven course and Brady's
ruined that for everybody yeah he has
and so for Philip like the reason why I
think it's a little bit more on him is
simply because often two coordinators
have cycled through there and they still
haven't snuck the football right like
you would think that if it was the
coordinators fault that you know maybe
one would try sneaking and one wouldn't
or something like that but it's pretty
been it's been pretty consistent I think
neither of them are as informed as they
need to be about the benefits of the
sneak and I also think from when I was
talking to the former starting Center
for the Chargers Nick Hardwick
remembered Nick Hardwick with Philip
Rivers for years he's about added
sleeves up his arms he mentioned the
fact that you know after Philip Rivers
tours ACL and played in that playoff
game with again I think it or ACL and
MCL against the Patriots like he was a
little bit less mobile after that and
maybe that is factored into it to some
respects but Wow yeah I'm definitely
disappointed in their decision-making
all right so a lot of you guys enjoyed
last week when we looked at strength of
schedule and instead of focusing on the
year ahead we're gonna focus on just
this week it allowed me to hit the
overrun Gardener men
chew on a prop that I did by the way
Gardner Minshew had a hundred ninety
passing yards in the first half against
the Bengals and finished with like 255
so I barely at the over but I was
looking great I was like the dude has
200 yards in the first half which is
exactly what we spotlighted we also
spotlighted last week that Dalvin cook
could pop off if you watch that game
every time Dalvin cook touch the ball it
looked like he was gonna go 70 but they
would tackle him at like 9 but again I
played Alvin cook and daily fantasy he
was good enough to make me some money so
this is something that that's pretty
good but we're only gonna focus on the
biggest drastic changes for this week it
was another thing people liked by the
way Warren so let's talk about a team
that has faced a tougher or relative to
this week a tougher passing defenses and
this week it gets a lot easier who
jumped out to you in the strength of
schedule mismatches there's a big
mismatch in favor of the Detroit Lions
going up against the New York Giants if
you look at what Detroit's had to face
the last three weeks they've played the
past defenses of the Kansas City Chiefs
and you might think all the Chiefs
defense is just mediocre they're
actually ranked fourth best in
efficiency against the past the Green
Bay Packers are the sixth best pass
efficiency defense and then they play
the Minnesota Vikings on their top half
of the league pass defense suddenly they
get to face the New York Giants who
ranked sixth worst in the NFL so that's
going to be a big edge and one of the
reasons why I think we might see Matthew
Stafford end up passing the ball a
little bit more here because they lost
carry on Johnson there Ron game might
not be quite as productive as they were
accustomed to seeing so those passes
down the field should create more upside
for them starting this weekend and it's
a big jump in ease of schedule for them
so a lot of people right now maybe
focusing on carry on Johnson missing
you're saying now's the perfect time to
maybe load up on Stafford for this week
because he could bounce back in a huge
way
absolutely it's Stafford in some of his
receivers if you pick the matchups in
the cornerbacks that you want to attack
these it's with wide receivers in
fantasy it's always about usage so which
guys do you think are you can you eye
identify our gonna get the most targets
in this game but definitely Stafford
should be in for a pretty good day
passing the football all right so that's
the passing offense that suddenly gets
easier for their schedule what about the
running offense that the schedule is
aligning for a big week in week 8 so
what I start to do as we're looking at
weeks 8 onward is I'm not looking at the
whole course of the season I start to
focus on what team has played a
difficult schedule over the last month
and now we'll get a lot easier and that
team is the LA Rams I'm fascinated to
see how they do on the ground they did a
little bit better against the Atlanta
Falcons Atlanta has the fourth best run
defense it's pretty surprising a lot of
people look at that deep end to say
trash Dan's defense is trash but they're
actually pretty good against the run
they've been real bad against the past
they lost their safety and Trufant was
also injured and so they were dealing
with a lot of injuries there and their
past defense has been abysmal but if you
look at the Rams that we know they're
run offense has been bad it's actually
factoring into making their overall
offense bad because jerod Goff's
doesn't have that punch when he drops
back to run the football so his pass
game and the whole play-action thing
just doesn't seem to be clicking quite
as well but if you look at who they've
played on average the number can run
defenses when you look at the Tampa Bay
Bucs who are really good the San
Francisco 49ers the Seattle Seahawks and
the Atlanta Falcons over the last month
now they play the Cincinnati Bengals
over in London who ranked 28th that's
5th worst in the league so the the
problem from a fantasy perspective is
there definitely is a Carey split going
on with the Rams so they're Darryl
Henderson got like 13 carries I think
last week yes exactly and you do wonder
though like and this is where reading
comes in handy read the quotes from John
McVay is he going to tell us that
they're gonna rest you know Todd Gurley
a little bit more in this game because
he just played last week after missing
some time so will they rest him a little
bit they're traveling overseas to London
and one thing that we know about players
flying overseas especially that distance
the plane has to get more altitude
and when the plane gets more altitude it
increases your swelling and so I'm going
to be interested to see we're whether or
not that's a factor with Todd Gurley and
his knees and how many carries he ends
up getting in this game and will they
choose to get a little bit more for
Darryl Henderson so this is one of those
things where you're literally gonna
listen to what Shawn McVeigh says
because of the increased swelling in
terms of the higher altitudes because
we're going over an ocean there is a
chance that we might see a lot of
Henderson this weekend so this is one of
those like late plays where if he's
available in the waiver wire if you're
playing daily fantasy and you can get
them at a cheaper rate that you might
want to wait a little bit and see
because it's such an easier matchup and
he might get more carries we might have
a low-key sleeper play here absolutely
now the other factor that I I wonder you
know is what what's the score of this
game going to be you have to forecast
that for you know so you can figure out
well would they let Gurley rest a little
bit more but the other thing that's the
over-under right now is forty eight and
a half forty and a half so the other
thing that's interesting is when it
comes to Todd Gurley is you know will
they try to reward him and give him some
of those goal line touches
you're not from a yardage perspective oh
just from like a regular fantasy
perspective will they reward him when
giving him those touches even if it's
later in the game or will they let
Henderson take them over I've always
been and I'm gonna go on a little bit of
a tangent and I apologize but it's a
good teaching point just from my
philosophy if I was coaching some of
these teams I don't understand why when
a game is relatively decided do you not
let your backup running back come in
there and take some of the workload from
your starter I had no idea why the New
England Patriots and Who am I to Tony
Michelle greatest coach in the world but
why is Sony Michelle in there taking
those carries at the end of the game he
actually got injured the trainer's had
to come out and walk him off the field I
don't think he's like he's gonna miss
time or anything but why subject him to
those types of carries that a backup can
deal with that won't determine the game
whatsoever you've got a long season
ahead and what's the most injured prompt
in the league it's your running back so
you know I would be I'm more inclined in
those games I take out my starter way
early and if I want to reward him a
little bit I can stick him in in the red
zone some and let him switch some
carries in there to keep his mind
involved and you know you don't want to
there's some running backs right who who
could do really well from a yardage
perspective but they care about their
touchdown well you don't want to piss
those guys off by oh well we're not
gonna use you in the whole second half
because we can let this other guy take
the workload because we're up by a point
you know you want to let those guys get
some of their touchdowns and whatnot and
remind their backup that he is still a
backup and he still has a lot to play
for and proved in this league but I
don't want to subject my starter to all
those carries so I would definitely if
we think the Rams favor by thirteen I
have a big early down success rate edge
I don't I'm not advocating laying the
points over in London with the Rams here
I'm just saying if you feel that way and
if you think the Rams are a good play
here then maybe there's a really good
chance that the you know their backup
running back will get more run in this
great matchup and could be a good play
for fantasy as you mentioned I love that
alright so then last week the one
defense that you said had a very
difficult schedule and then had the
biggest shift towards easiness in terms
of strength of schedule was the Saints
and the Saints were all over the Bears
until the Bears you know changed history
and got the first onside kick recovery
like the history of the sport and ruined
my team under but I'm not I'm okay I'm
okay
[ __ ] but it was still a good pic the
Saints dominated the Bears offense so
what defense in terms of strength of
schedule has a much easier matchup in
week 8 and they've had all season long
it's once again the Detroit Lions
against the Giants and Wow in it either
case you know again I'm looking at the
last month and they did have a bye
sprinkled in there but but they played
three top five offenses in the league if
you want to look at the Chiefs that was
when Patrick mahomes was healthy then
they played the Green Bay Packers and
then they played the Minnesota Vikings
so the last three opponents they faced
have been like
the best in the league nobody's had a
more more difficult schedule over the
last month now they get to play the New
York Giants now are the New York Giants
going to be a little bit better than
their 26 overall ranking because they've
got se Quan Barclay and Ingram back and
they're a little bit healthier yeah
they're probably going to be a little
bit better but it's still a massive
decline in strength especially of
opposing quarterback when you're talking
about Daniel Jones as putting him in the
class of Patrick mahomes and Aaron
Rodgers and yeah Kirk Cousins is Kirk
Cousins but when you when he can run the
ball and you use play-action he's not
playing a prime-time game he's in pretty
good shape and even if you want to
backtrack and look at what the Lions
face the first three weeks of the season
they were still playing teams like the
Philadelphia Eagles in Philly the LA
Chargers with Philip Rivers and they
were the first ones who had to deal with
Cliff Kingsbury's offense they were a
big in that game and obviously Kingsburg
came back and gave him a tie so this is
definitely a big drop-off compared to
what this team has dealt with we know
that they're getting there without
vondre digs who is very useful in the
run game yeah it'd be a problem against
a qualm barkley we also know that you
don't have carry on Johnson so let's
presume that the lines are in a good
spot later on in this game will they
struggle to run out the clock could that
provide more opportunities just like you
had to deal with the Bears last week
where the Giants are getting more
possessions late because the Lions are
having trouble icing this game again
absolutely not advocating laying the
points with the lines I'm just saying if
the game flow goes that way yeah it
could be an issue for their defense to
have to deal with so they need to really
be aggressive with converting first
downs late in the game if they do a
palete and don't just rely on their
backup running all right Lauren I need
you to help me parse this out so the
Lions are facing a much easier past
defense than they've faced all year
they're facing a much easier offense of
their opponent at the same point your
EDS are rankings have the Giants having
an advantage over the Lions how do we
balance that well I could tell you what
some of the sharper guys are doing and
we mark a little bit of dabbles on the
New York Giants at least at this point
in the week that line opened seven
there's some eight and it's been bet
down there's some six six and a half
cell
there now I'm not major nothing major
yet on this game you can still easily
get a seven if you want to take the New
York Giants here but that's just a
little bit of what they've been nibbling
at so far this week you know a lot of
the sharp guys were on the Giants last
week however yeah and week obviously
that did not go their way against the
Arizona Cardinals I like the Giants in
that game I thought they were going to
have success but and they really overall
did a pretty good job against the run
game really limited Cuyler Murray but
little chase Edmunds right he was just
burning these guys with a couple
explosive runs and they couldn't get
their hands on that short guy
so yeah I'm surprised like somebody
needs to measure up him like they were
measuring up Tori Cohen but hilarious
I think my thing is that I've realized
is it important to blend the analytics
and the advantages with real life and
expectations and for me we've seen a few
times this year where the Bengals had
the advantage in one game the Giants
have had advantages last week in Arizona
but when you get quarterbacks with rough
offensive line play against teams with
good pass rushers it's not that good to
take now the Lions are interesting
because they don't create a lot of
pressure they have a lot of good
stalwarts on the d line that are great
at stopping the run but like last week
Arizona had Chandler Jones that was just
gonna get around and get four sacks on
daniel Jones and Daniel has a set as a
fumbling problem I look at the Lions and
I go oh I don't think that se Kwang's
gonna have any huge lanes to run through
but I also know I'm not sure if Daniel
Jones is gonna be under pressure the
entire game definitely an interesting
game to look at from both sides but I
really don't like betting on Daniel
Jones right now he just him and
Tannehill like they both have huge
fumbling problems and I don't I don't
like betting on quarterbacks that have
fumbling problems because that's how the
game can turn like that it remembers you
win the turnover battle 80% of time
you're gonna win the game so you can't
afford to lose possessions especially
when you don't even pass the football
right and one of the things that we know
when you don't even get the attempt off
but you're fumbling it in the pocket
that's really bad news stress
all right so let's look at some of the
games of the week a lot of games at one
o'clock but to be honest we saw two
games at four o'clock that interests us
more and the Sunday Night Football game
which could have been the game of the
year and now I don't even know if it's
the game of the week so let's start off
at four o'clock Raiders Texans we
circled this because one it's very rare
when a team trades a cornerback to a
team that they're gonna play that week
which is odd the the Raiders do what all
GM's love to do which is trade former
first-round picks that were taken when
you weren't working there so this time
Gary and Connelly they trade him
the Raiders due to the Texans know am I
ever saying that correctly yeah which is
wild and you believe that it that this
might not be a game where you're
circling the side but you're circling
the total what jumped out to you for
this Houston Oakland game well I'm
looking at the two second areas of both
of these teams that I'm also looking at
the Oakland Raiders pass rush so what is
the biggest problem if you're looking
just a big picture let's look at the
Houston Texas what's the biggest problem
for this offense the biggest problem is
how are we going to protect John Watson
we have to keep this guy upright well
what is beneficial when you're facing a
team that ranks third worst in pass-rush
win rate that ranks very below average
in just overall adjusted sack rate which
is what the Oakland Raiders are they
can't get pressure I mean just one of
the things about Aaron Rodgers in that
game last week he's just standing there
in the month
nobody's coming up getting any pressure
he's just spin it up all wherever he
wants to put it because it's easy on the
quarterback so I envisioned a Shawn
Watson having a similar style of game
that he had against the Atlanta Falcons
who similarly could not get pressure and
just like the Atlanta Falcons the
Oakland Raiders are very good stopping
the run they actually rank above average
stopping the run and so it behooves the
Houston Texans to throw the football on
them it's just sort of like the
Philadelphia Eagles a better run defense
than pass defense why waste your
firt and energy running the ball on
these guys when passing is more
efficient in the first place and they
have a terrible past defense I'm looking
at the Houston Texans and I'm thinking
that even without will fuller right the
biggest concern is on that side of the
ball of these we don't have will fuller
in this yeah so that's a big concern
however you actually have other players
that are healthy when will fuller has
been injured in the past they only had
the andre hopkins really as a reliable
receiver now he got Kenny Stills who you
just added to the roster he actually has
a better average depth of target a
higher catch rate like all these metrics
in his time in Houston than even will
Fuller has had and they may have keiki
Katti underneath which is like a perfect
slot receiver exactly and he's healthy
he's missed time in the past he's a good
to go player their tight ends have been
a little bit more reliable yeah he bends
and fells have been good day because if
the fells have been very good and now
you actually have Duke Johnson a
receiving back out of the backfield much
better than what they've had in the past
so I look at the fact that you don't
have your number one to eat and I was
not eating a big deficiency in this game
and I look at the Oakland Raiders
defense and if we want to talk about
Gary on Conley Darren Conley is
absolutely terrible if he's buddies pen
in wit with the Oakland Raiders he's
been really bad I'm talking like bottom
10 out of like a hundred and fifty
hundred forty cornerbacks based on pro
football focuses charting of what the
passer rating is against him and now
he's like one of your better he's a
full-time starter for you and now he's
going over to the Houston Texans okay so
now your secondary Oakland secondary
whatever you think of Conley it's going
to be a little bit worse right it's
going to be a little bit worse without
him and if you look at this Oakland
Raiders past defense I think they're
actually gonna be in for a big problem
in this game and then on the flipside
because every time that you're looking
at betting and over it takes two to
tango is really us we are seeing big
issues around the NFL look at that
Dallas Cowboy
game if you bet the over and a Cowboys
game you are sitting so pretty in that
first half and then there are big the
Eagles offense isn't doing anything you
slow the game down you start running the
ball more all of a sudden boom the game
doesn't even go over the total so I'm
looking at this Oakland Raiders offense
and I'm saying they need to be able to
score they need to be able to do well
here there is a chance that they're
going to be getting back one of their
better receivers obviously they've been
playing without Tyrell Williams for a
few weeks there's a chance they're
getting him back starting right tackle
Trent Brown he was listed as doubtful
last week yes Jon Gruden brought him to
Green Bay because he thought there was
an outside chance he could play when you
read something like that it signifies to
me this guy's probably pretty close to
coming back and guess where you might
need a good right tackle as against JJ
Watt coming on your quarterback strong
side so having Derek Carr strong side
protected by there right there starting
right tackle is going to be big and
hopefully they will get them back there
and you know the other thing is look the
Houston Texans have been dealing with
injuries to their secondary - they just
played placed Phillip Gaines who's
played 97% of their steps they put him
on IR last week he's done Jonathan
Joseph went out of that game Bradley
Roby missed the game he hurt himself he
hurt his shoulder and he's definitely
out this week from what I've read Adam
Schefter indicated Roby is definitely
out this week I also saw - Sean Gibson
hurt last week - yeah just I just I
remember writing it out of my notes
against the Colts that he got helped off
by personnel he may have come back but I
know that he was banged up in the game
and so they put on the field this guy
named Lonnie Johnson he is a rookie out
of Kentucky second round pick rookie out
of Kentucky you know you know you're not
you know your stuff Johnson's allowed
you know that Johnson allowed all four
passing touchdowns from jacobi percent
last week well here's the thing about
Lonnie is because I used to live in
Kentucky very cocky kid like I was
watching him in pre-season and he was
like all up on people but he gets burned
and he keeps coming back so you're
telling me all four of touchdowns
from Jacobi % were on Lonnie Johnson
that's great yes and he was when
targeted he brusett went 9 for 9 for 97
yards a 10.8 yards per tempted through
four touchdowns on the kid and you don't
think Jon Gruden one of the things that
Jon Gruden is not good at is doing
player personnel and making decisions
and valuing guys one of the things that
Jon Gruden
is great at is watching film drawing up
plays on how to attack and scheme things
up so he's that popular phrase Warren
his popular phrase is when he sees
something wrong in a defense he goes it
is our duty to continue to do this to
them so that they can learn how to be
bet it is our job to do this so how do
we figure out who Lonnie Johnson's
guarding we'll have to look at where he
lined up last week I don't have that
information right now hopefully the 33%
can do some homework or I can look up
yeah I'll look it up or left cornerback
the other thing that we know is he knows
Gary on Conley I mean Conley was a
starter for them and played terribly now
he's likely going to be starting this
game for the Houston Texans he's going
to be coming in a little bit late
doesn't know the scheme quite as well
gonna have to pick it up very quickly
and then going to be put out there on
the field and Gruden's going to be able
to use some things to pick him up
apartment medical you love the over in
this game big temper Jon Gruden played
with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers against
the Oakland Raiders in that super pole
and one of the reasons why they want 48
to 7 or whatever was is because he knew
all the tendencies and all the trends
for the opposing offense and defense
because he was with Oakland the prior
year lacrosse it was what period
commonly does well and doesn't do well
alright so let me just give you a little
bit of their Nuggets Raiders are for 13
and one against the spread in their last
18 road games three and 15 straight up
in burr found this I thought it was
incredible as a starter Watson deshaun
Watson is 18 and 11 and all 11 losses
have been by one possession whether it's
in the 50s or the 20s he's keeping his
team in it by the way before we go on to
Panthers Niners I
have a little bit of other nuggets about
games we've already talked about Eagles
bills Philly is one seventh of their
last eight games against AFC teams I
thought that was interesting
bills as a favorite or eleven and two
straight up seven five of one against
the spread but when the Bills have a
favorite edge on you they're just
they're able to maximize that the other
one was their London game Bengals Rams
Cincinnati four of their six excuse me
four of their games they've lost by six
points or less and when you look at who
it's been against it is kind of
impressive at Seattle at Buffalo Arizona
and at Baltimore
they've lost by 6 or less they've kept
some of their toughest games close but
listen this about Sean McVeigh against
the AFC nine and Oh straight up six two
and one against the spread for McVeigh I
just wanted to get those trends out
there before we move on to Carolina
49ers so Carolina San Francisco this
game is in San Francisco
late game four o'clock I believe it is
the game of the week six and Oh San
Francisco 49ers four and two Carolina
Panthers
I'll get the trends out first Carolina
has beaten San Francisco six straight
games San Francisco has not beaten
Carolina since 2001
that's 18 years I don't know if that
matters to anybody since 2012 Carolina
is 5-1 and one against the spread on the
west coast I don't know if that matters
to anybody
San Francisco is one and eight against
the spread in their last nine games
favored by more than six points as we
are recording this though right now San
Francisco is a five and a half point
spread so that trend doesn't matter but
a lot of the trends favoring the
Panthers a team that you have been very
high on all year but you've also been
very high on the Niners this could be a
phenomenal game I'm curious what you're
seeing right now the first thing that
jumps out to me is the pass rush of the
49ers they're doing such a good job of
getting pressure with just four down
linemen and that allows them to flood
the secondary and take away throwing
lanes and really mess things up and what
does Carolina like to do Carol
likes to throw the football lot to their
running back Carolina likes to throw the
football lot to their tight ends and
that that's where having those
linebackers in space who are not rushing
but are dropping back
those guys flood the lanes and the
locations where tight end and running
back targets typically are completed so
that's something in favor of the 49ers
here that's working against the Carolina
Panthers the other thing is I'll let you
speak to this
the 49ers just acquired a starting wide
receiver from the Denver Broncos and
Emmanuel Sanders gonna be a big piece of
this offense because he came from a risk
and reloj offense which works with Kyle
Shanahan so he's going to pick up the
what Cheney hands putting down really
quickly with the terminology and
everything like that yeah like so you
saw that and and I think you saw
Emmanuel Sanders coming to the 49ers and
said okay Rick scangarelo worked under
Kyle Shanahan and now he's going to Kyle
Shannon's offense and I know that the
communication between Kyle Shanahan and
John Lynch have been very good in terms
of Kyle saying I need this type of
personnel or kind of really looking out
for you think Emmanuel Sanders it's not
going to take a long time for him to get
up to speed you think he could almost be
immediate his impact on this team
absolutely and the other and so like
these are the types of things that when
you you do this for a living and you're
focused in on this you're thinking about
like the next step like oh yeah they got
this guy but then what does it mean oh
well it actually means that he's going
to integrate very quickly seamlessly
because of the terminology in the style
of offense the other thing is focus on
this the 49ers didn't want the Denver
Broncos didn't want Emmanuel Sanders to
be traded before he played his next game
they wanted to keep him there for his
next game and the 49ers like this is
only happening if we can get him
immediately because we want him to play
for us against the Carolina Panthers so
they are definitely under the impression
that they need him for this game and the
fact that he's familiar with the offense
I think it's gonna be a very quick
integration for him so that's it that's
a big thing in
favor the 49 we both have over bets on
Carolina for the season
I have been saying very proudly that the
Panthers front 7 is the best in football
and their past defense has actually been
great but I know that you actually think
that the strength of schedule has been a
little bit favorable for the Panthers
lately and so it could get actually
surprisingly dicey against this Niners
pass offense and the Niners have been
more of a running team this season they
have and and I'm interested the thing
I'm interested to see about this game it
really gets down to like the
nitty-gritty matchups here is how much
are the 49ers going to run the football
because both their starting tackles are
still out this game and you just
mentioned the strong pass rush of the
Carolina Panthers it is one of the best
in the NFL it actually ranks second best
in the league the only catches they've
played the eight easiest schedule of
opposing offensive lines but what 49ers
when they don't have both of their
starting tackles and their fullback
who's good at picking up guys in pass
Pro so could Carolina disrupt and get a
little bit pressure on Jimmy Garoppolo
so far year-to-date the San Francisco
49ers ranked fifth best in adjusted sack
rate for their offensive line so they've
been doing a good job of keeping Jimmy
Garoppolo upright but this is really
this is the best opportunity that you
know toughest opponent they face from a
pass rush perspective so that's
something interesting as well when you
look at the attack you're right they are
a little bit more run based and that's
one of the things with out he want short
you can run the ball a little bit on the
Carolina Panthers
so I am going to be fascinated you know
how that plays out on that side of the
football
what about Carolina's offense Niners
defense to me it's the Christian
McCaffrey which has been a runaway train
against the Niners which is I would say
other than the Patriots the most
formidable defense in the NFL right now
I agree a hundred percent the only thing
about the 40 not there's not too sure
about yet is they have played themselves
the eighth easiest schedule of past
defenses the fourth easiest schedule of
overall defenses I'm sorry that's what
you mean yeah they played the eight
the schedule of opposing past offenses
and the fourth easiest schedule of
overall offenses now they have Carolina
which is actually a little bit better
than what they were weeks one and two if
you carve out the Cam Newton starts from
the Kyle Allen starts hairline is a
little bit better then you also factor
in that Kyle Allen had to come in like
right away and start playing against the
Arizona Cardinals without a bye week to
prepare or anything like that
his performance does look a little bit
better he's another guy though that we
talked about hold on to the football in
the pocket Kyle Allen combs is riced
I should have said that and so I called
them to loosely problematics got tiny
hands and that's an issue when you're
talking about this pass rush with Bocek
coming around the edge and the Carolina
offensive line really is not a strength
of their team right you see do you see
McCaffrey having success against this
team is what do you think well I think
that it's going to be hard it's
definitely one of his toughest opponents
I think they're going to need to be
balanced they can't get into a game here
where Kyle Allen's dropping back
throwing a lot of passes against this
pass rush so they're probably going to
be a little bit more balanced and that's
one of the interesting things the
Turner's have been very progressive with
their strategy they're passing the ball
a lot more than they used to pass the
ball in years past which is odd because
you think Christian McCaffrey but
they're given him his touches through
the passing game and they're still there
like 60% pass on early downs which is
definitely above the league average so
will they scale that back a little bit
against the 49ers great pass defense and
pass rush velocity I just personally
this is this is just me talking I don't
know if there's really that many teams
that are five and a half points better
than Carolina I I really believe that
Caroline is that good of a team I know
that San Francisco has been great but I
don't know
it is Carolina and they are coming off
of a bye I'm gonna get into sort of the
by Records updating that after we get
through these games Sunday Night
Football could have been the game of the
year
Packers Chiefs mahomes Rodgers it could
have been really special and because
we're not getting mahomes that
has completely flipped the look-ahead
line had the Chiefs favor by for right
now the Packers are favored by four and
a half and that's the power of Patrick
mahomes an eight and a half point swing
that goes through seven different
crucial numbers just some other trends
for you
first some injury news that this was
people were talked about yesterday
it is looking like Eric Fisher Sammy
Watkins and Chris Jones might play in
this game which would be monstrous for
the Chiefs because everyone's talking
about how bad that cheese defense has
been how they haven't gotten a second
two games until the public realizes that
Chris Jones is phenomenal I'm gonna just
continue to bang my head against the
wall because that's how good Christians
is Matt Moore
this is an Ingmar stat twenty and ten
against the spread as a regular season
starter consider me shocked that Matt
Moore has played 30 games as a starter
did not realize it was that many games
Green Bay's defense has allowed over a
hundred and fifty yards rushing three
times this season or that she's gonna
commit to the run I don't know
Kansas City won five and one against the
spread in their last seven against the
NFC Green Bay six and one against the
spread in their last seven against the
AFC I don't know what that means to you
but I always think about familiarity and
how teams do when they're facing a team
they have it maybe faced in the last
four years where would you like to start
Warren well I've got to start with Matt
Moore replacing patch from our homes in
some like I'm not gonna sit here and
argue that this is a good thing for the
Chiefs but the only good thing that
could come of this is they needed to get
their run game jump-started a little bit
and getting Eric Fisher back certainly
would be big in that regard but they
cannot continue to go through a season I
mean they're leading the NFL in passing
attempts in in pass rate it's not bad
it's not bad to be passing more than
running but they aren't focusing enough
on running down in the red zone you know
there was that game we talked about it
on the show three weeks ago we're inside
the opponent's 40-yard line
Patrick mahomes threw the ball 17 times
and there was only one
and it was to me Cole Hardman on an
end-around it wasn't even a running back
rushing attempt so they've got to focus
a little bit more on trying to get their
running backs involved and assisting the
offense the reason why I'm saying that
because it sounds contradictory because
I love passing and it's more efficient
but there's got to be a little bit of
balance from a play caller there's got
to be a little bit of change-up if the
defense gets too comfortable that all
these guys are doing and dropping back
and passing then you're pinning your
ears back you're rushing the quarterback
a lot more often so you're telling me
right now that your issue the cheese has
been they throw too much and now because
their starting quarterback is out who's
a generational Talent and because
they're facing a run defense that has
been very porous this could be a good
game for Andy Reid to adjust his offense
and really start pounding the LeSean
McCoy and the Williams guys
and if he doesn't is that going to give
you a lot of concern about this team
kind of going forward just strategically
yeah but yes it would it would but I
don't think he's going to do that I
don't think he's asked the ball 70
percent of the time with not more a
quarterback against this secondary I
think they are going to be running the
football a little bit more now you're
we're gonna look back on this game if
the Chiefs lose on Sunday night and say
well should they have passed more did
they run too much we're gonna like
dissect whatever game plan he brings to
the table and say if they lose say well
maybe he should have done this right
there's gonna be second-guessing
regardless so we can't sit here right
now and forecast it like it's definitely
going to work and so he should do it he
should run the football more but they
need to try to be providing that more
with a little bit less responsibility
and carrying the weight on his shoulders
like he was able to entrust with Patrick
mahomes all right anything else to get
to you with this game that you want to
talk about well we got a good past the
offense of the Chiefs it goes overlooked
because the runn defense is so bad but
Aaron Rodgers may not have quite the
same level of success as he did against
Oakland who have no pass rush and who
who's secondary is very porous as we
mentioned we broke down the first game
of the day so I'm
looking at this game and I'm seeing yeah
Aaron Rodgers like he just played the
30th past defense last week of the
Oakland Raiders a couple weeks prior to
that he was playing teams like the
Philadelphia Eagles and the Dallas
Cowboys seeing some success passing the
ball on those opponents
you know he's Davante Adams gonna
practice this week could they get him
back I have no idea it's still too early
to really figure that out yet but I
think that there's gonna be the
opportunity for the ground game here and
if they run the ball a little bit more
that could keep this game a little bit
tighter and if the game's tighter that's
what the Chiefs need to be able to run
the ball in the second half it seems
like an old refrain but you need to be
able to keep the games close against the
Packers so that you can run the football
in the second half against a bad run
defense as opposed to pass the football
against top six seven pass defense left
code translation that I'm hearing if
Kansas City wants to have a chance to
win they need to run the ball if Green
Bay wants to be successful in offense
they're gonna need to run the ball I
then look at the screen sharp football
analysis calm I see the over/under of 48
and I go wow a lot of running the ball a
lot of wasted clock okay just you know
just processing things together right
because passing teams you get more plays
in the score goes up running games
typically the game goes faster the score
is down I don't think I'm reading too
much into this I think this actually
sounds smart warrant no and look that's
exactly what you want to do for anybody
who's as you mentioned at the beginning
taking notes and processing things you
want to look at some of the information
that we're sharing on here and try to
make some of your own decisions I'm not
advocating a play on this one way or
another but you can put things together
and start figuring out I mean
unfortunately this game for people it is
Sunday night everybody wants to bet on
the Sunday night game so you take in
some of the notes you figure out what
you want to do once you've processed all
your information at least from the left
Kosho you're getting this style of
analysis and so you're able to use this
information with some of your own
handicapping and and decide to what to
do
it's honestly [ __ ] awesome that it's
Sunday night because what happens is
people chase so they're gonna lose
someone o'clock sand 4 o'clock bets and
they're gonna go you know what
remember that touchdown that Matt Moore
had to Tyreke kill I bet you as a good
game and that Kansas City defense stinks
and Aaron Rodgers I mean the Rodgers
just had six touchdowns last week so how
do you know if the public is gonna go
the opposite of you are with you how
like because for me I'm already
convincing myself that I'm betting this
under I'm very excited about it
but how do I know if people are gonna
get desperate and bet the over and drive
it up more and and how do I know the
value of the number of what I'm getting
now versus what I could get later how do
I do that well that's that's an
interesting conundrum that you're gonna
be faced with because you don't have
necessarily yourself the connections
with the syndicate groups to know what
they've bet or what they're about to bet
and in this case this total opened at 48
it's now sitting at 47 and a half and
some 48 so a tiny bit of under money has
come in typically on a Sunday night you
will see people chasing and the public
across the board typically bets overs
ditches I usually I'm gonna try to get
out early on a total unless there's a
situation of injuries or weather but in
every case I am really studying the
market I mean I sit in I wish you guys
could see like six monitors here and my
projection screen and the three other
TVs back there but I'm sitting in this
bunker it's more or less for 18 to 20
hours a day working I'm sleeping for
like four hours at night and my line
screen is this massive TV screen right
in front of me that I am never without
access to and so I'm constantly looking
at well where's the line going or is is
heading to try to time things so as the
example we bet the the over in that
Baltimore Seattle game ultimate at the
very last minute at the very last minute
like 30 minutes before the game because
we were waiting as the market was
ticking a little bit down Sunday night
typically the only way this is going to
come down I would just tell your
listeners this the only way this go
below 48 is if it's sharper syndicate
money on this if it's below if it goes
below that then you know if you bet the
under you're gonna be riding with those
guys if it words the over the fact of
the matter is it could be either a
little bit of the public influence
chasing or it could be a sharper
syndicate group who is chosen to bet the
over and normally you're gonna see a
larger line move like this Lionel will
jump pretty substantially to like 49 49
and a half let me let me let everybody
know your little speech there about four
hours of sleep let me say one other
thing that Warren said to me that made
me laugh so hard because I knew that
he's in a different level I said Warren
you know I really don't want to have an
experience like I did last Sunday where
I turn on Washington San Francisco I see
like the entire field underwater and
realized that my bet is completely
[ __ ] because now like this weather
screwed up let me go to weather.com and
see what the weather's gonna be like on
Sunday and Warren said weather.com screw
that
that's not reliable I have my own
weather code that I've made and I'm like
the fact that you believe like everyone
goes to weather calm or they go to their
phone and you're like not reliable I
have my own ways of getting weather
information that's the level that
Warren's at and it I will warn when we
hung out last night I was dying laughing
because to me that's where you're at is
you're fine-tuning the weather it's
incredible yeah I have I have a script
that I run and I'm pulling weather
graphics and I'm actually I anticipate
because I've studied I know what URLs
certain weather websites are going to
publish when they publish their future
reports and so I've goes up already the
the system does it automatically for me
so they haven't even like released the
weather graphic for like the wind speed
or the wind gusts Sunday at 1:00 p.m.
but I already have it cued into my
system so that when that graphic gets
published I know the URL it's going to
be the the the picture the JPEG that is
yeah and I can pull it in automatically
there's other like wind speed things
because wind is so important that I use
other sources for wind in analysis and
information like I literally the only
time I'm going to weather calm is I want
to know like what's a forecast gonna be
when I go up to see left co in New York
you know in a couple of days I just want
to know what the temperature is and is
it gonna be ranged that's all like I'll
use weather calm for that on my phone
app but other than that of when it
relates to football I've got my own
process it's [ __ ] incredible and by
the way when we looked at it before the
show there was no inclement weather this
weekend so there are no games that we
really jumped out to because look I'm
gonna be honest I when that happened
with Washington San Francisco 33% I was
like hey from now on if there's any game
where there could be something like that
we're gonna jump all over and make that
a part of the show there was nothing
this week in terms of post by week
records we had told you a few weeks ago
that teams that were home after a bye
have been historically awful teams that
have been away after a bye surprisingly
good the numbers thus far not barring
that out but we're playing this season
which means it's probably gonna come
back that way
so teams that are at home after a bye
thus far have been three and two against
the spread but it's Warren pointed out
to me all of them have been very
explainable week five the Niners against
the Browns Niners home after a bye
member Kyle had all those extra
practices week six Miami versus
Washington Miami home after a bye don't
forget Washington was up 17 to 3 and
then Ryan Fitzpatrick came back and
turned that one week 7 Colts vs. Texans
Colts at home versus a bye Frank Reich
is one of the most forward-thinking
coaches the NFL and for two seasons in a
row he's been one of the only coaches to
win at home after a bye he did it last
year against Jacksonville as well away
teams after I buy those teams have been
surprisingly good thus far this year 1 &
2 against the spread one of those Jets
on the road after I buy it was Luke Falk
he was not on the team
a day later which shows you all you need
to know about that situation and week 7
the Raiders were the other team that
didn't cover last week against the
Packers and we talked about before if
Derek Carr doesn't fumble out of the
endzone that might be a completely
different game but you can always find
excuses and so I will admit that but the
four games this week in which there is a
team after the by Carolina at San
Francisco so this is again Carolina team
that you know pretty interesting and
they are going away after a by Cleveland
away after a bye at New England Tampa
Bay away after a bye at Tennessee and
Pittsburgh at home against the Dolphins
after a bye and the two that really
opened my eyes there was Carolina at San
Francisco which we talked about before
and Tampa Bay at Tennessee and
interesting enough ETS are looking a
little spicy in those matchups two home
or yes
Tampa Bay actually has the edge in EDS
are over the Tennessee Titans now
Tennessee we have to admit a little bit
different without Marcus Mariota or yeah
a little bit more efficient able to
throw the football down the field a
little bit more I will say if Tampa Bay
I mean their problem has been their
secondary but if they can get a little
lucky you know Cana was firing that ball
in like without regard it seemed like
for some of the where the charger
secondary was and you could pick off
I think he's highly pickable if you are
in the right location so I like that for
the box and of course they are really
good stopping the run so Tennessee might
struggle to run the middle run defense
have to rely on Tannehill the ever
pickable one and then on the other
matchup that you mentioned Carolina of
all these four teams Carolina Cleveland
Pittsburgh and Tampa the one that I
think is the most forward-thinking or
most likely to understand what a bye
week means and adjust accordingly would
probably be the Carolina Panthers nah
this is a team that just went over to
London okay
and they had to figure out when are we
gonna go how are we gonna do this well
how are we gonna rest how are we gonna
eat how and they came out and look
really good against Tampa Bay obviously
so what they did was certainly superior
to what Tampa Bay did heading over there
now it doesn't help when Jameis
Winston's your quarterback and he's just
throwing picks left and right now but
Carolina's got on track very quickly
offensively in that game to a team that
they lost to earlier in the season right
so that was a very impressive victory
two weeks ago I think that they probably
are going to be not to the level of
Frank Reich and Kyle Shanahan but headed
in that direction on that half of ground
zero to being a team that's going to say
hey let's let's have an extra practice
let's let's bring these guys in and get
their heads refocused on this game
earlier than some other teams might be
laughter yeah meanwhile like the Browns
I have no faith in what they did in the
bye weekend like the Pittsburgh Steelers
with Mike Tomlin like I'm sure it was a
lot of hoorah speeches
whereas Carolina I could definitely see
them getting in the lab some trends on
these games first Tampa Bay at Titans
were used at Tampa Bay actually has an
EDS our advantage over Tennessee I've
been loving them right away because
Tennessee should have lost that game
like variable going forward on fourth
and one with Ryan Tannehill which led to
that Chargers coming down and the
Chargers having two touchdowns taken
away also people the last image they
have of Jameis Winston is those five
interceptions which I love when that
happens
last time I checked this spread
Tennessee what do you know they're two
and a half point favorites which is like
my least favorite spread in the world
but Tampa Bay is 500 and one against the
spread and their last six Road games
against the AFC if you like trends
here's a Cleveland Browns Patriots one
that Inger found Brady since 2001 has
won 244 games
the Browns since 2001 have 192 days
unbelievable and then in terms of
Pittsburgh Miami that Monday Night
Football Mike Tomlin is 6a no straight
up among the Night Football but he's
also three and three against the spread
Steelers and there
last five games favored by double-digits
and in this game right now they're
favored by 14 and a half
oh and five against the spread went
favored by double digits and let me tell
you something
whoo I just realized you know who they
played on Monday Night Football last
year and it became a shootout Ryan
Fitzpatrick and the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
remember they went [ __ ] nuts
but Ryan Fitzpatrick is not a guy that I
want to bet against with a double-digit
sprint justice me the hard part with
Fitzpatrick when I'm looking at this
game there is one thing that I just want
to let people be aware everybody
probably already knows this but Ryan
Fitzpatrick just played the Buffalo
Bills last week that was his former team
youyou could guarantee the way that he
was playing and all the guys a fiery
competitor but he was extra juiced up
for that game and it was close they were
in it so you got this feeling of belief
and then the feeling one you actually
lose that game is a pretty big letdown
so this could be that letdown spot for
Ryan Fitzpatrick their offensive line is
going to need to protect we've seen the
Steelers pass-rush really improve and
and they're very good especially playing
at home on Monday night as you mentioned
under the bright lights they tend to do
pretty well but there is zero chance I
mentioned it before even when early down
success rates in their favor like I do
not lay points like this it's 14 and a
half right now the only way I could look
would be to back the Miami Dolphins here
if I were to do anything on it so
because we're recording on Wednesday
that means at the West Gate lines for
the Super contest have not come out yet
by the way I went two and three last
week I got Minnesota I got I know I
didn't get Seattle I know I didn't get
San Francisco who won by 9 I neither won
by nine and a half and then [ __ ] I
remember who else I picked I didn't get
the Giants so that was a third game I
lost and I got Minnesota and
Jacksonville was the other one I got
right so we're not gonna do Westgate I'm
not gonna call crack today but you can
still download the crack wins app I
still given out a pick a week and Bill
Kraken burger
one of the good guys in this space so
definitely check it out but one of the
other games that I just kind of circled
that I loved so it the games that I'm
talking about that I'm already looking
at the ones that are interesting me I am
looking at Carolina right now I'm hoping
that lying can get a little bit bigger
for San Francisco and people start
buying this Emanuel Sanders hype I am
liking the Tampa Bay Bucs right now some
of the other ones that I'm circling I'm
definitely thinking about Detroit
because the schedule stuff Saints is a
little bit big for my liking for the
nine and a half but the other one that
I'm liking a lot is the Colts because I
still think people are under selling the
Colts a little bit at last check they're
favored by six but these were some stats
that I found is that Denver right now
and this is an inverse that actually is
that in terms of converting third downs
they have the third lowest third down
conversion rate for a Denver Broncos
team in the last 30 years they were 1 in
13 last week Indianapolis their last two
opponents their combined record was 9
and 7 Kansas City and Houston their next
three opponents Denver Pittsburgh and
Miami are combined 4 and 15 so Indy look
they just beat Kansas City in Houston
and now they're taking on Denver it's a
little bit of a drop-off in terms of
offenses that this Indianapolis Colts
defense is faced by the way
Darius Leonard looked really good back
last week ad Malik hooker is getting
healthy also Denver 6 and 15 against the
spread in their last 21 road games
you saw my note and you said I'm gonna
dive into this matchup a little bit too
and you're focusing on the Vic Fangio
matchup against a kind of a Frank Reich
scheme what have you found so Frank
Reich was the offensive coordinator for
the Philadelphia Eagles in 2016 in 2017
that was Carson Wentz his rookie year in
2016 and Vic Fangio was obviously the
defensive coordinator for the Chicago
Bears so different personnel both sides
of the football
but how did this
kind of go up against this style of
defense this exact coordinator what he
what are some of the things that that
guy like to do and Frank Reich went to a
no in those games in Carson Wentz his
second start ever in the NFL they won 29
to 14 they made six trips into the red
zone they had scoring drives this is
what Philadelphia's offense did with
with Frank Reich calling plays they had
scoring drives of 77 yards 68 yards 47
yards 46 yards and 38 yards so as you
know anything above 50 you're starting
on your own side of the field so a
couple of the drives were starting with
good field position but several still
right around midfield and several on
their own territory and then so they won
that game 29 14 the next year they also
played the Chicago Bears week 12 they
had five trips into the red zone in that
game they ended up winning 31 to 3 was a
game that Carson Wentz threw three
touchdowns no interceptions
they had scoring drives there of 69 68
56 and 44 yards and he just neither time
did Carson Wentz have brilliant numbers
from like a yards per attempt or a
success rate perspective he did have
four combined touchdowns no
interceptions and only took three total
sacks over the course of combining those
statistics but it was shorter passes
getting the ball out of his hands and
that's exactly what you Kobe per set and
the Indianapolis Colts are doing it's a
lot of underneath stuff their debt
getting T Y Hilton involved a little bit
more often but I think they'll be pretty
prepared for this opponent and the style
that Frank Reich Frank Reich is using
against Vic Fangio should end up paying
off and having some semblance of success
here obviously Denver's without Emanuel
Sanders who's been a starting wide
receiver for them so important Sutton in
their tight ends are gonna have to carry
the workload there they're really good
at running the football but as you
mentioned the Indianapolis Colts are
getting better from a run defense
perspective that's the biggest worry
that I have in this game I always look
at games from slightly get effective at
first what's the biggest concern and the
Indianapolis close right now ranked 31st
and run defense
the Denver Broncos obviously a little
very run heavy team there's more strong
heavy team and they've got a couple of
backs that are pretty decent at running
the football so that's gonna just say
that Darius Leonard hasn't played for
the last few weeks and Jamal Shearer was
missing too and also I love Ben against
Joe Flacco it's the best because when
he's helpless you feel really confident
yeah it's definitely more fun you're you
feel better about your wager betting
against Joe Flacco than betting on him
at the end of the day though you just
want to cash that ticket so you make
whatever is the most plus evey way here
to make and we've been on Joe Flacco
before and has successfully been on Joe
Flacco and had failure so you know but
it is certainly you feel more confident
if you're going up against alright so as
we're recording this we still don't have
a line for like Seattle Atlanta they're
still missing some lines places Arizona
and New Orleans but I think we got to a
lot really quick I'm not gonna dive in
because I know you need to leave like in
the next two minutes any other nuggets
about Thursday Night Football since this
is coming out on a Thursday
the only trends that I have that I'd
like to share with people are Minnesota
is 15 and 5 against the spread at home
in their last 20 games Washington is 5
and 17 in primetime in the last six
seasons it's Washington fans are very
well known as we're recording this on
Wednesday
Minnesota's favored by 16 you just said
you don't really touch lines this big it
is the Kirk Cousins revenge game in
Minnesota is there anything here that
would add a little nuggets for the 33%
for Thursday Night Football well it's a
double revenge game chris is also the
case keenum revenge game oh excuse me e
that cancels each other out then well I
mean a better quarterback you know kind
of screwed it's not like her cousins
should be mad at the Redskins he got a
really nice contracted very well
negotiating that for himself by thinking
and getting a lot of guaranteed money
going to Minnesota probably a little bit
more than what he deserved but the fact
of the matter is if you can run the
football on the Redskins you're going to
be able to set things up in the pass
game again I don't I'm not going to be
very interested in the
Thursday night game but it is certainly
Thursday certainly something people who
want to bet on that's about all I have
to say about that I don't really have
any opinion yet formulated for any plans
or thoughts from a props aside your
totals perspective on that yeah unless
you want to just do money line and take
home eight dollars I think you'll like
it
Oh sharp and bright sorry interrupt
because you mentioned Carolina and news
came out Brian burns actually had off
off by weak wrist surgery
he says he's playing this week but he
did undergo surgery on his wrist during
the bye week so that's interesting
damn alright since we recorded this on a
Wednesday all the news and notes that
were giving you all of the lines and
trends pay attention to the injury
reports guys Friday like two or three
you don't need to be psycho like us and
look at Wednesdays and Thursdays and
Fridays but Friday late afternoon you
can go to a bunch of places you go to
roto wire.com and just look at how guys
are practicing before you put your bets
in it's very important sharp football
analysis calm is where you can find
Warren sharps work if you want to find
him on Twitter he's a great fellow
during the game I don't know how he
watches all of the games and tweets
constantly but sharp football is where
you can find him there and a lot of you
have asked where can I find strength of
schedule sharp football stats calm
anything else before we go Warren no I
think that's it you're the man if you
are in London
hit me up Sunday from four o'clock till
four in the morning I am watching
football at a bar O'Neill's on Carnaby
Street it's gonna be [ __ ] money sharp
you're the man bro I'll talk to you
later for Warren sharp
I'm the lef koe man real holla holla
holla at you next week
[Music]